the modern environmental movement began
in 1962 with the publication of Rachel
Carson's best-selling book Silent Spring
and ever since then doomsdayers have
been warning us about imminent
environmental catastrophes that
ultimately didn't happen we all worried
needlessly about acid rain expanding
deserts global cooling but these failed
predictions weren't quite dire enough to
make our list the number 5 environmental
disasters that didn't happen
frankenfoods frankenfoods one of my
favorite myth ten years ago
the greatest environmental scare story
was frankenfoods
in her book stolen harvest Vandana Shiva
wrote the gradual spread of sterility
and seating plans would result in a
global catastrophe that could eventually
wipe out higher life forms including
humans this was just nonsense up on
stilts back in the 1990s
finally some biotech companies were able
to to endow crops genetically modified
and genetic enhance them to resist pests
and to resist herbicides now there are a
lot of benefits today if you resist
pests for example then you don't have to
spray pesticides on on the plants it's
been a revolution in agriculture that's
actually been part of the solution to
improving food production around the
world every independent scientific body
that is ever investigated biotech crops
has found them to be both safe for human
beings and safe for the environment
every one of them the number for
environmental disaster that didn't
happen the end of biodiversity so these
scam mongers were claiming that our
emissions into the atmosphere and waste
into the water was going to be the major
driver of species extinction this for
example back in 1970s Dylan Ripley who
was the head of Smithsonian Institution
predicted that 70 to 80 percent of all
animal species would be extinct by the
year 1995 that didn't
those claims have become part of a
mantra from the environmental movement
not based at all upon evidence since the
1970s a total of seven animals have gone
extinct in the u.s. three of them were
small freshwater fish one was a
freshwater clam and two were very small
birds
it's sad that they are gone but this is
not a mass extinction the number three
environmental disaster that didn't
happen the energy crisis on the first
Earth Day in 1970 ecologist Kenneth watt
declared by the year 2000 if present
trends continue we will be using up
crude oil at such a rate that there
won't be any more crude oil the energy
crisis erupted in the 1970s after the
Arab oil embargo against the United
States OPEC the organization of all
producing come from countries organized
the cartel and that cartel reduced
output from an output of a good is
reduced and demand stays the same
prices rise and of course what happened
is our government did all kinds of
idiotic things under President Richard
Nixon we started rationing gasoline
among other things the reality is that
every time the these resources become
more scarce the price goes up and in
entrepreneurs identify new ways of
supplying us with energy the number two
environmental disaster that didn't
happen a Silent Spring we've already
mentioned the importance of Rachel
Carson's book to the environmental
movement but Silent Spring wouldn't have
grabbed the number two slot in our
countdown if Carson's predictions had
come true this book was arguing that the
use of synthetic chemicals and
specifically pesticides was destroying
the natural world that the spring would
be silent because the birds would all be
poisoned by our pesticides ever since
well people were worried about
insecticides because insecticides kill
things she also was arguing that the use
of these synthetic chemicals were going
to create epidemics of cancer so it was
a really apocalyptic vision that was
frankly based on a flimsy and inaccurate
representation of marginal science
pesticides are not a big deal in fact a
cup of coffee has more carcinogens in it
then you're likely to get from exposure
to synthetic carcinogens getting here in
response to all the hype about
pesticides governments around the world
have banned DDT and those bans have led
to some decidedly unpleasant unintended
consequences DDT was the most effective
chemical for controlling malaria
mosquitoes around the world the result
well now a million people a year are
dying of malaria there is a cost-benefit
analysis here do we want to save Eagles
we want to say people I think we can say
both but the fact of the matter is is
that the band was too harsh too strong
minces a serious human tragedy that can
be directly correlated to Silent Spring
and now the number one environmental
disaster that didn't happen Malthusian
famine in his 1968 book the Population
Bomb Paul Ehrlich wrote the battle to
feed all of humanity is over in the
1970s hundreds of millions of people are
going to starve to death in spite of any
crash programs embarked upon now we
couldn't save countries like China we
couldn't save countries like India we
couldn't save a whole bunch of places in
Africa and what we had to do in order to
to forestall this overpopulation trend
is to stop sending them food Ehrlich was
just spectacularly wrong basically if we
had followed his policies we would have
actually created the famines that he
claimed were inevitable
although population has increased
considerably food output per capita has
risen faster what has happened is is
that when Erik was riding it around like
seventy the average woman on planet
earth was having about five children
over the course of her life that is down
to two point four now and continues to
fall unlike animals what we do is have
fewer children and invest more money in
them and make them better off more
people are being fed better today than
at any time in human history